I mentioned log cleaning that has to be
done. Now as client activities go on, log
segments evolve on the disk. So for instance,
if on a particular client node some blocks
were written to the log segment, a log segment may fill up like this. And now
it is sitting on the disk. So the
blocks that are containing this log segment corresponds
to write to file blocks one, two, and
five. And these file blocks may belong to different
files, but it is okay. So, so far
as the file system is concerned, segment one is
a contiguous file. It is a log segment, but it is a file. And that's the one
that is residing on the disk. On the
client node, this particular block one may get overwritten
due to activity on the client. So now we have a new content for that same file
block one, one double prime. And once this new
content has been created, this is no longer valid,
and so block one is overwritten, which means we
have to kill the old block that was in
this segment. So there's a new segment in which
we wrote the contents of the new file block,
one double prime, and we have to go
back to this old segment and kill this particular
copy of that block, which is a stale copy of that same block. So we don't need
that anymore. So you can that see as
client activities progress we are going to create holes
in the segments. Remember that these segments are persistent
data structures on the disk. This segment was valid
at some point of time. But once that
particular block one was overwritten on the client
node, this segment contains the latest and the
current copy of that same file block. And therefore
we nuke this particular file block and so
we create hole in this log segment. And
subsequently, let's say that the client writes to
other file blocks, three and four. So the log
segment two contains one double prime, three prime,
and four prime are the blocks that it
contains. And segment one contains two prime and
five prime. One prime is not relevant anymore because
it has been overwritten by one double prime.
Activities continue on the client box and a third
segment is created. And that third segment contains
two double prime. That is, this block number two
is overwritten by new contents, two double prime.
And when this happens the file system has
to create another hole by nuking this two
prime to indicate that this block is not relevant
anymore, because there is a more recent version
of the block in segment three. So the
block two is overwritten, killing the old block.
Now you see that as client activities progress in
the entire distributed system, we are creating a
number of these segments, log segments on the disk,
and these log segments may progressively have holes
in them because they have been overwritten by new
contents, by activities on the client machine. And
this is what log cleaning is all about. It
has to do with cleaning up the disk and getting rid of all of this junk so
that we don't fill up the disk with unnecessary
junk. So for example, what we want to do is
recognize that we have three segments here, and the segments
have holes in them. And what we are going to
do is, we're going to aggregate all the live blocks
from all of these segments in to a new segment.
So we've got five from this segment that is still
alive, and from this segment we've got one double prime,
three prime, and four prime that are still alive. And from this segment we've
got two double prime that is still alive. So we have coalesced all of the live
blocks from the existing segments into one
new segment. Now once we have aggregated this
into one new segment, all of the old log segments can be garbage collected and
that's what log cleaning is all about. And
this is very similar if you think about it
to the way we described cleaning up the
diff files that are created in the DSM system,
Treadmarks. And the same thing is happening except
that these data structures are on the disk we
are conserving the space on the disk by getting
rid of all the old log segments and garbage
collecting them and saving this space once we've
aggregated all the live blocks in these segments into
a new segment. So this is what log
cleaning is all about and in a distributed file
system, there is a lot of garbage that
is being created all across the storage service. And
we don't want this to be done by a
single manager. We would ideally like it to be
done in a distributed manner. This is
another step towards a true distributed file
system by making this log cleaning activity
also a distributed activity. So log cleaner's
responsibilities include the following. It has to find the utilization status of
the old log segments. Then it has to pick some set of log segments to clean, and
once it picks a certain number of log segments
to clean, it has to read all the live blocks
that it finds in these log segments that it
has chosen for cleaning, write it into a new log
segment. And once it has done that, it can
garbage collect all of those log segments. So this is
the cleaning activity that an LFS cleaner has to
do and in XFS they distribute this log cleaning activity
as well. Now remember that this log cleaning activity is happening concurrently
with writing to files on the nodes in the distributed system. So there are lots
of subtle issues involved in managing this log cleaning in parallel with new
activity that may be creating new log
segments, or writing to existing log segments.
I encourage you to read the paper that I've assigned to you, the XSF paper, to
get a good feel for all the subtleties
that are involved in managing log cleaning concurrently with
writing to the files. So in XFS they
may make the clients also responsible for log
cleaning. There is no separation between client and
server. Any node can be a client or a
server depending on what it is doing and each client, meaning a node that is
generating a log segments, it is responsible
for the segment utilization information for the files
that they are writing. After all the activity is happening at the client end in
terms of creating new files, and new
file writes are manifesting as creating blocks and
log segments in XFS. And so the clients are responsible
for knowing the utilization of the segments that
are resident at that client node. And since we have divvied up the entire
space of servers into stripe groups, each stripe
group is responsible for cleaning activity that is
in that set of servers. And every stripe
group has a leader, and the leader in that
stripe group is responsible for assigning cleaning services to
the members of that stripe group. Recall that the
manager is responsible for the integrity of the files
because it is doing metadata management. And, requests for
reading and writing files are going to come to
the manager. On the other hand, the log cleaning
responsibility is going to the leader of a
stripe group, and the manager is the one that
is responsible for resolving conflicts that may arise
between client updates that want to change some log
segments and cleaner functions that want to garbage
collect some log segments. Those conflicts are resolved by
the manager. These again are subtle details which
I want you to read carefully in the paper.